what's going on okay currently right now
with the sec case against ripple we have
a bunch of notes here but bring
everybody up to date on what's going on
right now with the lawsuit well right
now we're waiting on a couple big
decisions from the judge there's a
decision a motion to strike ripples fair
notice defense and a motion the most
important motion i believe because i
think the fair notice one's going to be
an easy one for them to decide it is the
internal documents at the scc the their
documents on bitcoin their documents on
ethereum there's even a document dated
june 13 2018 on evaluating xrp and
whether it's a security and the sec has
refused to turn any of these documents
over they're claiming they're privileged
and they're claiming they're privileged
pat
even though
they claim that they've never made an
official declaration on bitcoin or
ethereum they've actually rescinded bill
hinman's speech in june on june 14 2018
where he said look ether is no longer a
security bitcoin is not a security
they've all
walked away from that and so that's why
this case is so important if the sec
successful i can guarantee you gary
gensler is coming after ether
potentially and not so much bitcoin but
every other altcoin so so there's three
audiences you're talking to today so i
just want to kind of give you this
perspective so you know as you're
communicating
the typical audience you talk to they're
all crypto community so when you drop in
names and all the stuff they know right
so when you drop in verbiage they know
when you're saying certain things they
know today's community
is consisted of those who are xrp ripple
which you're very comfortable talking to
them number two it's the community on
the crypto side that don't own xrp but
they own bitcoin and ethereum and
they're concerned about what's going to
happen with you because not you they're
concerned what's going to happen with
this case because
we know gary is hired and appointed i
think february 3rd of this year by
kamala and biden as the sec chair and he
used to be the the commodity futures
trade commission under obama before and
then prior to that he was under clinton
so he's a full-blown democrat they know
it and we know kamala
biden uh one of the game plans that they
had is they were there was a couple
things that were not comfortable about
us why they brought gary and gary is not
a fan of spax they're trying to little
over regulate specs you're aware of that
because last year there was about 100
billion of money raised for spax the
last 24 months so spax are in the up and
come they've been around for a while but
it's been a lot of momentum lately and
the other thing they're worried that
they cannot regulate is why they brought
gary in is cryptocurrency they would
like to figure out a way to make
crypto a security because if they do
they can now control it they can now you
know regulate it they can do a lot of
different things so for the audience
that has no clue what's going on okay no
clue what's going on
let's go through
uh uh uh your initial passion on why you
as a former marine lawyer who's
extremely skeptical why did you all of a
sudden say look man i want to see what's
going on here with crypto this is kind
of interesting to me what was appealing
to you all right well first thing i did
i did what a lot of people do i read the
bitcoin white paper okay
fell in love with the concept of
cryptocurrency bought bitcoin bought
ethereum bought xrp
and just sort of went
a firm believer you know i think you
said in an episode 40
of all u.s dollars printed in the last
what year yep 18 months it's staggering
and so looking as an alternative a hedge
on inflation or just an alternative to
fiat currency that's being debased every
day right so that's what got me involved
what got me involved in this suit pat
was i'm just an investor i'm not a
securities lawyer believe it or not i'm
actually amicus council in the biggest
securities case since
1946 and i've been practicing a
securities law for about
nine months right but when i read the
complaint as an xrp holder i learned
that the case was filed i was expecting
to see what you always see in these
securities cases that the sec would say
you know what brad garland house you
know what ripple when you sold xrp in
2013 to 2015 on this specific
transaction on that specific date that
was an unregistered security and that's
what i expected first paragraph xrp
itself is a digital asset security and
it's an unregistered security from the
very beginning of time until today so
according to scc
including the secondary market pat
if i go right now and i buy xrp from
uphold and i don't have any idea of
ripple
they're saying that's an unregistered
security and so it's something very
different they're attacking trying to
set a precedent against the token itself
and in the case the seminole case that
they go off is this case called howie
from the supreme court in 1946
it involved orange groves
and the sec never said well the supreme
court never said the oranges are the
securities they said the scheme and the
marketing and the packaging the way that
the company sold it that was an
unregistered securities offering they
didn't say the tracks of land were the
security they didn't say the oranges
were the security the underlying
instrument pat is never the security
it's the way you offer it and package it
but in this particular case they went
after the token and pat for eight years
it was sold in the united states and
worldwide 200 exchanges
they allowed ripple to purchase nine
percent of moneygram
they had a settlement with fincen in
2015 where they called it digital
convertible virtual currency this was
being allowed to go on and on and on and
all of a sudden the former sec chairman
jay clayton on his last day as he's
walking out the door
slaps this lawsuit the most significant
sec enforcement action in my opinion in
modern history in a non-fraud case and
goes after the token and there's so many
conflicts of interest that we're going
to get into jay clayton was just on tv
today on cnbc and and they asked him
again what about these conflicts that
everyone is uh calling you out on and
he's like i'm not going to talk about it
because it's pending litigation there's
no pending litigation over your ethics
right but he refuses to answer these
questions stuff we're going to get into
yeah so so the the and by the way the
current of the case against sec
doesn't xrp have like some of the most
incredible uh team right now the former
sec chairman is one of their
representative who do they have on their
team right now who's ripping up on their
team right now it's outstanding yeah
that's what that's married
mary jo white former sec chairwoman
former sec chairwoman's on on their team
yeah former director of enforcement a
guy named andrew serezni who was the
director of enforcement is their lead
trial attorney this is ripples yeah and
they also have uh
on their team
former scc
person in charge of new york's office
and they actually have someone who used
to be the director of corporation and
finance on their team
ripple has an all-star
team as far as defending this case so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]